but i had to do the ghost pepper that
was uh that was how was that experience
that hurt see because like you know you
guys were saying like oh you know and
everyone in the chat was saying oh look
forward to the next morning like you're
gonna you're gonna be [ __ ] through a
straw and i was like oh god no no the
ramen was way worse yeah the ramen was
way worse than we had but um yeah i was
fine like i had maybe like one painful
[ __ ] and then i thought that was going
to be like the beginning of the end no
no no no no no no no
no the one that spicy is the yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah i was fine after that
i just you know i look back on the this
clip of me like shivering for 15 minutes
afterwards and i'm like i literally look
like i'm about to [ __ ] die
yeah i was like getting slightly worried
when you start shivering yeah i know
it's because your body is just going
into shock yeah pretty much and uh you
you're like your body is rushing you
with like [ __ ] adrenaline and
endorphins and all that kind of [ __ ] and
i just remember seeing you like go like
this and i'm just like so you are you
arriving
and like you know i think the worst part
about it is when you watch that out of
context you see a dude who looks clearly
sleep-deprived with like huge bags under
his eyes shivering i just look like a
crack addict
like i just look like i was having
withdrawals i was like sleepy like
[Music]
it was not the best look i don't think
the sleeve deprivation helped as well
because i can't imagine trying like
trying a food that you really
it's seven in the morning yeah it was
seven in the morning we were up for like
20 hours at that point and you're like
perfect time perfect time to eat a
ghostbuster no
to be honest i couldn't taste anything
oh yeah there was no flavor was it as
painful as you thought it would be i
yeah i i find that like sauce
sauces like really like heavy
sauce-based dishes that are spicy or the
hardest to eat because like you know
like the hot ones stuff yeah i can eat
all of those hot one sauce like the
hottest ones on wings like no issue like
i don't need milk or anything like that
it's just it tastes good like the last
dab i like i like slather everything in
that right and it's all it's all good
because it's just a few bites but it's
very solid
but like we did the ramen video for
yours yeah and that wasn't that spicy
like it it i'd say like it's not as
spicy as like a
ghost pepper or a carolina reaper yeah
because it's just sauce yeah it coats
your mouth
coats your like esophagus and then it
goes into your stomach and it it hurts
so much yeah and then it takes a while
so you just keep eating yeah eating i
definitely struggle more i think with
that than the ghost pepper one burst of
spice is not that bad it's when you keep
eating bursts of spice yeah yeah like
that
multiplies yeah you don't you don't give
yourself a break that's why like eating
one carolina reaper for me is like
totally chill like i could do it now and
we could still film the episode and it'd
be chill yeah
eating like those competitions where
they get like 40. i'm like that's fine
how has anyone not died from that that's
[ __ ] i don't know because
i don't think you can you die from spice
no you can go into shock though you can
go into shock but i don't has there been
a recorded spa uh recorded case of
someone dying from spice i'm not sure
if there is there has been you can burn
a hole through your stomach
i don't necessarily think that's true
though i think yeah you'd have to have a
pretty weak stomach though i feel yeah
because like it's a factor of things
cause like for me as someone who like
loves spicy food like trying to explain
why i eat spicy video why like you know
like joey's joey's said to me all the
time like i don't know how you can like
get through that or something like that
and i think one thing that's really
under
like underrated about why people eat
spicy food is that the spicy food needs
to taste good yeah you know because we
when we think of like spicy challenges
we just think about getting through
getting through how spicy this spicy
meal is or getting through like this
[ __ ] pepper or something but a big
draw of spicy food is that if it's even
if you're in [ __ ] pain and you know
your mouth is hurting if it tastes good
with the spice
you want to finish it and you want to
eat it because it tastes good i mean
that was it with the ramen video like i
would not have finished that if it
didn't taste as good as it did yeah and
it tastes really [ __ ] good if that
did not taste good i would just been
like no [ __ ] this yeah like i felt like
for example like the koko ichiban level
10 spice and it is spicy but it doesn't
taste good at all like it just feels
like you're making it spicy to make it
spicy it's artificial it's just
artificial right sometimes it just feels
like you're this is just you know this
is just a flex at the end of the day we
can make it this spicy but it doesn't
even like the taste doesn't marry well
with the spice at all and it just like
if like proper good spicy dishes need to
taste good it needs to complement the
actual base food yeah yeah exactly like
i have like for example i have like thai
food without the spice and it literally
does feel like there's there's a
component that's missing from the
yeah um
so good yeah are you gonna say astrid uh
capsaicin
does cause uh tissue inflammation so if
a large enough dose could cause serious
damage to your stomach i feel you'd have
to have like an egregious amount though
to hit that point uh or something really
spicy and have it all in one sitting you
could do enough damage to potentially
kill you
um i i just uh uh
my ex-girlfriend was sri lankan yeah i
remember when i went to to meet her
parents and stuff
everything had chilis in it
it was amazing i loved it yeah i was
like it was like breakfast omelette with
like five of those peppers that you put
in like thai food yeah yeah
and i i ate them all and then i don't
know if i told the story her mom came in
and was like
why did he eat the peppers
and i was like am i not supposed to eat
the peppers and she was like no you'll
get stomach cancer if you eat the
peppers i'm like why would you put them
in the food
what the [ __ ]
they were delicious
like it was good yeah there's also like
another restaurant because she took me
around to a bunch of the local
restaurants and there's one thing where
it's like deviled mutton it was called
or something yeah and it was like that
sounds badass it was like the most
delicious
marinated mutton i'd ever had in my life
damn but it was like like doom level of
spice or if it's got the word
yeah
and it was like i'm tearing up but i'm
like [ __ ] it's so good
and it was like even though i was in
like so much pain i'm like just another
bite
it's so good that that's the thing about
spicy food if it's really good spicy
food you're like you power through it
you pound i just just one more bite yeah
you take the bite you're in a pain but
you're just like oh it just tastes so
good though i don't know how to explain
it but like when it's super spicy and
super delicious it's almost like it's
searing in the flavor yeah
this is so much flavor ah because it's
almost like if you take the spice out
because of like for example i've had
like very
you know i've had unspiced thai curry
i've had unspiced indian curry as well
in england and uh
the best way i can describe it is that
it just tastes flat you know it tastes
flat there's something that's missing
from the taste right uh
uncarbonated
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of that's
a good analogy actually it's it's you
the flavor's there but there's like a
texture so the flavor is there but the
personality is gone exactly
you know if you have rice with it too or
you have naan i feel like that's so nice
to have like spice with it because yeah
yeah yeah yeah it kind of helps mellow
it out a bit yeah yeah yeah yeah see
because like i never for the longest
time i didn't understand that concept of
like spice enhancing food because you
know up until i'd say maybe like three
or four years ago i could not handle
spice at all like if i went to kokoichi
i would do like level one which is like
the most basic [ __ ] and i'd just be like
no too spicy i can't do it and then i
don't know what it was that like where
just one day i kind of just flipped a
dime and i was like
you know what this it hurts but i'm
enjoying it for some reason